if they know like their gender for
example then like like if you're like a
woman right you know that you don't know
what you want to order tonight
you know and that's why they're hungry
because they're women yeah like you know
that you need your guy to like just be
like [__] it like I'm just gonna pick
one and like yeah we'll just get Thai
food okay man
welcome back to another very special
careful boys we are very careful boys
and today we're talking about what is
your thoughts on victimhood in 2023
victim like like being a victim it seems
like something that people wear proudly
these days it's a hot thing like a
victimhood t-shirt they like to put it
on and everyone and everyone look yeah a
little bit what's on the T-shirt bar all
kinds of different I do think during
Colby which thing it really brought up
so many of the things that were boiling
just in American society
but then like
some of it felt like oh finally there's
Justice and then it started feeling like
that feels extreme and then some of it
was just like what the [__] is this and
then so many things just felt weird
right like
I'm at this point now where
nothing feels like honestly motivated
right like back then when you saw a
social justice movement before kovid it
was just like oh these minorities are
fighting for equality and you took it
for face value really like you didn't
see the ulterior motive or like
now it's like all these things coming
out like like we supported BLM and then
we found out that the founders embezzled
the monies bought mansions and white
neighborhoods in white neighborhood yeah
they didn't even they didn't even give
it to the people that they were saying
they're gonna help yeah and then the
George Floyd family didn't get a dime
out of it and all that stuff and I was
like
dude now it's like everything is like
you gotta question everything yeah
everything's for theater yeah just to do
this thing and then it's a narrative to
sell a story yeah yeah cell is the right
word it seems like there's times where
people
use the flag of being a victim and then
figure out how to monetize it or
capitalize it all in some way you know I
mean whether it's just notoriety Fame
credibility or straight up money you
know there was you know there was a
group even in the in the dance world
that was using you know the uh BLM
movement and just being like
um you know like this is uh people gotta
learn and unlearn certain things and
realize that all this culture came from
like black people in history and stuff
like that so in order for you to learn
that you got to pay us for our lessons
and it was kind of like it was a really
confusing time so I I guess maybe maybe
that could make sense but then once they
were like gaining money on stuff and
like actually taking money from people
for these like lessons on stuff like it
just kept on turning into this habitual
cycle like trying to find the next
person that could be you know convinced
that there was some sort of
victimization to this one unique group
that could figure out how to continue
monetizing this concept you know what I
mean so it it like Joe said it kind of
just made you slowly start to question
the entire Integrity of some of these
like you know claims and stuff and I
think unfortunately it turned
um just the perspective of that time
into something where you're like yeah
like you said you just have to start
questioning more stuff because and when
you're the victim you can't actually
begin to solve the problem because it's
happening to you so for example when
like all the Asian Elders are getting
beat up and then then you see all these
Asian influencers going oh then the
politicians need to do something
everybody's got I'm like what are they
gonna do are they gonna say hey beating
people up is illegal I mean it's already
illegal you know like everything that
you just shout out oh why is it
happening to us like none of those ever
become a proactive thing people like Ron
setting up like the the seniors fight
back seniors fight back that's do
something forward they're learning some
skills they're going forward just to
film fill people in who don't know
there's a period where a lot of Asian
Elders like senior citizens grandmas
grandpas like in metropolitan areas
they're like the target of a lot of just
random acts of violence like cars roll
ups getting socked in the back of the
head and [__] like that probably because
they know it's like easy target I think
it had to do with like just really dumb
people thinking old Asian people were
spreading covet and they're the reason
or something and it's just like a period
of angst or people are just mad they
want to take their anger out and so it
was a lot of Asian uh senior citizens
getting attacked and then so of course a
lot of the more prominent Asian figures
they come out but it's in a way where
it's a very like victim t-shirt coming
out like don't do this to us or whatever
but it's like when whenever you say that
it's not constructive you can't do
anything about it you're not proactive
versus the people that are actually
going out setting up like these little
seminars or like doing like situational
awareness things and actually trying to
push it Forward because then once you go
I can take control of this situation you
can actually do something about it if
you're always like it's happening to us
what are we gonna do someone else got to
do something yeah it's never gonna right
you can never control the situation or
improve it yeah Ron did something about
it yeah he did a like seniors fight back
like in like at a big Park he did
multiple classes where he was like he's
a pro fighter huge classes yeah so he
would have all these seniors come out
like this is what I would do some State
award for one of the
most like big like non-profits that gave
back during this the couple of years and
stuff but what do you do so they
literally were teaching free workshops
to senior citizens like Asian seniors
and stuff and it's called seniors fight
back teaching them how to like
self-defend yeah you know what I mean
versus what Bart's saying people are
just like jumping on the ground being
like this is baloney yeah yeah why is it
happening to us you know um this group
that basically were pushing the whole
like stop Asian hate whatever right they
got like a eight-figure fund wow and no
one knows where that money went where
it's being spent it's like some NorCal
Asian politician group like political
group I don't know like they're just
it's a non-profit they get the money
from just donations no the government
the state of California wow yeah that's
what the stop Asian hates it's like some
it's like some hate it's like some anti
I I'm butchering this but I saw it
um on next shark
no the commenters would have done
something about that Joseph
the commenters on next shark are
changing the world yeah
at least when they're not being [__]
with by this guy
Korea's number one and in the way of
God's work I think also um when the
media shows that something's getting a
lot of attention people that want
attention do that thing yeah they go
like oh victims are kind of at the front
page of everything I too am a victim you
know it's like when you're in class and
a jealous kid also wants to have the
same problem you do it's just that it's
like when you're watching Shark Tank and
someone's like hey it's like I'm doing
like a green injury green energy thing
and then everyone all the sharks like
this is on Trend this is great sure yeah
it's like it's so transparent sometimes
but yeah but I think even with like the
not the people that want attention but
just that mentality is so big now that
it's hurtful to themselves because they
feel like they can't control anything so
there's even like people that are like
like big food like that's the reason why
I'm fat or that's the reason you know
like they need process yeah they're
gonna change the supermarkets I'm like
or maybe you can change your dietary
behavior I'm a victim of the FDA yeah
yeah it's like if it could be dirty
everybody else's responsibility yeah
like your your relationship your
spirituality or your intellectual every
single thing your whole thing is
everyone else's responsibility but then
if that's the way it is then you can't
control anything you can't improve
anything yeah it's true I kind of feel
like um
right now it's this big Awakening right
it's it's woke but it's like right now
um see I've always been cynical and and
and
untrusting of Institutions and
government but I think what kovid did
was really bring that out because
um this guy was I was watching this
podcast and he was explaining how like
it started really with the war in Iraq
uh everybody was like when we when 9 11
happened
all of America was like we need to get
these terrorists For Those About to Rock
dude remember that it's a billboard
everyone was like we were hungry for
Revenge everyone was like they're
attacking America and what happened
we're like hey we got to go there for
wmds we didn't find any and then all of
a sudden it's bait and switch why are we
in Afghanistan like why are we you know
and then that happens right
fast forward like there's so many things
where Obama continues the words why
strange people start to lose more and
more trust with the government they vote
for a guy who says hope and change
that's changing hope and then oh we got
the same [__] as always oh and there's a
CIA document leak that says like yeah we
wanted a noon face for the wars and it
was Obama but even before that right
like there's like certain things like
the bailouts when when everybody fit
like and all these guys getting bailed
out insurance companies and what do they
do they go on Private Island Vacations
million dollar [__] bonuses right and
then everyone's like watching this
unfold and say there's no accountability
no one's getting in trouble and then
little by little it's chipping away at
this fabric of like Americans trusting
the government or anything about 2008
happens right housing crisis
who's helping kick people out of homes
Obama who would have saw that coming
yeah hope and change again I'm just
saying the narrative is busted like it
and then people don't vote for him again
in 20 2012 but that doesn't really
matter because like he's running against
Mitt Romney it's like oh [__] so he got
less votes right as an incumbent
president he wins re-election less votes
but yeah people are more cynical now
because of what Joe's talking about I
don't think Trump would have won I agree
if they didn't exploit the public so it
was literally Obama voters actually who
who turned the tide for Trump yep
statistically you could look at it in
all these different precincts it was
Obama voters who carried the day for
Trump because I think what happened to
the American public is they were so sick
of politicians they were like let's just
try this business guy he doesn't seem
corrupt roll the dice and then now we're
at this point after kovid where it's
gone so far where
it's like we have corporations now that
are virtue signaling and also like using
social justice as a marketing plot
during pride month let's make a [__]
rainbow rainbow vodka or whatever right
and then yeah and then so like these
movements are the Integrity of the
movements are just capitalized yeah it's
all just it's all gone and I've said I
said this like the victim stuff and
people are so sick of hearing it what
pisses me off is that like you know it's
like blue-haired white guys are just
fighting Republican white guys and it's
still white people fighting white people
talking about whatevers and then
minorities that had a point in certain
things it gets really muddied and then
now you have a Karen who's talking on
behalf of Asians or whatever the [__] is
going on and it's so muddied like it's
just so muddy yeah that's probably the
worst part is the worst part it's
pandering victimhood hides the real
victims yeah because real victims don't
tend to want to be known as victims and
there's transparent things like why do
you need like it's like hey we need
rainbows like I said vodka or whatever
the [__] it's like we put a rainbow flag
on it and it's like you got rainbow
sherbert right there's waiting for
something but I do something with it and
rainbow sherbert's just sitting there
with his [__] hand on his dick just
like he's been gay the whole time yes
the whole time like hello I'm literally
already rainbow let's go nobody plugs in
nobody or Fruit Stripe gum exactly I
mean loses flavor so fast it does it's
quick that would be anti-gay kind of
because it's like oh you're kind of
trying out being gay but then you're
back because it loses flavor so quickly
but you know what does suck though is
when let's say there is an actual issue
right like let's say there is a real
issue that let's there's this community
here they just have the shittiest
resources the shittiest school systems
they need help whatever and if they
speak out they're like yeah yeah yeah we
have other [__] we need to worry about
like trying trans issues or whatever
something takes precedence right so then
like these groups that have knots that
have been suffering for so so long and
been asking for decades for help they
get overshadowed by all these different
groups now the trendy problems yeah oh
yeah because right now the whole
narrative is about like sexual
orientation all this stuff and I'm like
what the [__] does that have to do with
like all the people in poverty right now
in America like that's probably gonna
should take priority right like how
about the hungry kids like that probably
takes priority versus like understanding
gender studies or whatever like I'm not
I don't want to downplay it but it's
still if you weigh out the two which
one's more important yeah what's going
to move the needle far yeah and then we
completely forget that that still exists
in America and then now it's like all
these other things are the loudest thing
and I'm like what the [__] is going on
but do you think it's like if they know
like their gender for example then like
like if you're like a woman right you
know that you don't know what you want
to order tonight
you know and that's why they're hungry
because they're women yeah like you know
that you need your guy to like just be
like [__] it like I'm just gonna pick
one and like yeah we'll just get Thai
food [__] it man yeah yeah like you
don't you're just gonna sit here for
like 35 minutes like we're gonna go
hungry like that come on babe that's the
real test of what's gender yeah it blows
my mind so the men are the victim in
that situation in that situation I think
we are yeah
clarified yeah yeah sometimes we are the
victims well then what do you think of
like reparations for instance
reparations become dial it up extremely
hard out of zero to whatever value they
said it's hard to create a fair outcome
because of like how how do you put a
price on it because some of the [__]
that's been done it's just so [__] up
it's like how do you put a dollar sign
on it and another thing is how do you
trace specifically the legacy of it so
like let's say it's been done to your
great great grandpa but now like he
might have fathered so many kids so now
his ancestors there's like 600 people
that's linked to that one grandpa that
was hurt so like my thing is like why
not and all I mean by that and this
sounds like grander and why not go ahead
accuse me of it but but
okay so we'll just happen with covid all
this [__] money gets printed they
hand it to all Wall Street I'm like
let's see what happens when we [__]
just hand it to some people who like had
a shitty lot in life maybe like your
ancestors were slaves let's give you
some money I like I'd rather it finally
go to some people who are people than
going to where it always goes to every
[__] time yeah yeah every yeah it's
like the first time it goes to someone
else why not it's actually going in the
hands of a person let's see what happens
it's a real person
or something
four people here that's been needing
money whatever reason you want cut me in
oh they weren't slaves I don't care just
fine they're real people like they're
not like Raytheon or [__] Lockheed
Martin let's try it out
I say [__] it I roll a dice on that
because maybe it's not so much
following the direct descendants the
structures yeah but maybe it's about
like hey if you're gonna spend
frivolously like that then why don't we
spend it on American citizens exactly
yeah God forbid what I said during covet
oh people hating on me all the time the
whole time but what I say you could give
everybody in America like 20 grand each
or whatever but instead no they printed
it I'll give it to Tom Brady or whatever
piece of [__] by the way
and that that's true that should drive
people crazy why did Tom Brady need
money right like why do people like Tom
Brady need money or why did all these
big [__] corporations all these Wall
Street places any money oh I know why oh
Steve because of their 401ks all the
people's 401ks and all [__] like yeah
enjoy your like little amount of percent
every [__] year I got wrecked on Luna
I'm still beating you
like it's disgusting our financial
system is a joke cryptocorn every
Tuesday I think
what I don't like about the whole
victimhood thingy right now is that it
distracts from actual victims and then
we can't see who needs it exactly so
like it's like if you if we were a
hospital right and all these people are
coming into the emergency room we're not
treating the people that's been shot and
they're bleeding to death right now
we're here treating someone who's
sneezing exactly
Chris Rock said right is that he said he
said all we're doing is we got like a
million paper cuts we're trying to treat
exactly well yeah and I mean like we
could get to it I'm not gonna just write
it off and say that whatever they're
dealing with isn't a problem I'm it is
but we have to like go through the tears
you gotta prioritize yeah if there's
kids in poverty and they're not [__]
eating a good meal every single day why
don't we deal with that we have so much
food in America that's probably the
first thing we want to deal with what
about Ukraine first Ukraine first and
then because they keep hungry yeah
someone else's kids first is there is
there by any chance a projected actual
amount of money that it would take
Ukraine to win the war is there like an
actual like we just need this much and
we'll win for sure no we have to
constantly keep sending more and more
and more and more so what kind of a
nickname
quick yeah go ahead Nick that's my
[__] job dude that's Nick's job I
dare you to really make me sit here and
research for like 45 minutes what's the
Vladimir Putin's favorite color I guess
it always just also comes down to like
the story that we as a society get bored
of you know what I mean it's like maybe
like the priority if you like really
list the problems that have to be solved
financially or whatever maybe the answer
is always going to stay the same for a
very long time because it was such a
huge problem and it's like oh well we're
[__] bored of this problem with
something else that maybe has seen but
that's how you get real actually
productive it's getting good at fixing
boring [__] yeah but you know what I
mean though like in terms of just like
Society American people it's kind of
like well
this one's new and exciting and maybe it
takes a little bit less maybe we should
just try that instead and we just like
completely disregard some of the more
you know the larger power I'm more
scared of like the kafka-esque effect
that happens when like let's say we have
a new problem and we're gonna put money
towards it and we're going to build this
whole team to take care of it the
problem never gets taken care of because
the team doesn't want to be disbanded
and start losing money
that's what I'm scared of it's like
every new problem gets that new team
like TSA will never [__] get rid of
it yep it doesn't matter they're going
to keep doing nothing yeah hey look at
the new restriction act right with Tick
Tock it's like hey uh you use a VPN we
want to put you away for 20 years
you heard about that [__] no oh that
sounds terrible if you're using a VPN on
like using some kind of app like Tick
Tock for example which is what they're
basically making this act for yeah
um and you're using it but you're not
supposed to you could go away for 20
years what the [__] the restrict act
dude 20 years 50 years so just for tick
tock just for using an app that you're
not supposed to use not approved by the
US government team what about Netflix
can I use a VPN on Netflix so I can get
channels from other countries 25 years
well no now Netflix is cracking down
anything about that like only so many
accounts dude go [__] yourself yeah I
mean the problems the problems are
money makers for somebody that's all it
is which is why they'll never solve it
right it's like every single time
somebody like cures cancer it's like
what the [__] there's a cure for cancer
and those people get like [__]
silenced or some [__] it's because
there's no like money in curing cancer
right there's only money and [__]
trying to fix it and there's honestly no
money in continuing this video because
we're done
oh